hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal in dem wir mal
wieder auf ahlmann - reagieren
ich habe ja schon mal auf deutsch -
reagiert als wenn jemand auf ihren
reservierten platz sind es die neben
soft die wir heute reagieren sind vor
der instagram seite albaniens also
schaut auf jeden fall gern mal vorbei
allerdings fangen wir jetzt auch schon
mal mit dem ersten und zwei autofahrer
braucht beim einparken zwei versuche und
albert sagen natürlich direkt
führerschein im lotto geworden dass
genau ich tatsächlich das nächste - auch
einfach wieder so typisch deutsch ist so
typisch ahlmann einfach komplett und
zwar sagen leute eher einfach macht gut
ein ahlmann sagt allerdings macht besser
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dort wieder so auftrat durch weiß
überlaufen radiosender spielt songs von
tim bendzko reimann annette
ja also dat is wirklich 100 meinem namen
des nächsten moment keine richtige
überschrift in dem sinne sondern schaut
einfach selbst der ahlmann schmeißt eine
bowlingkugel auf der quasi mehr oder
weniger steht ist die aus dem
altkleidercontainer und der schweiz ball
die kugel auf jeans mit löchern und das
war immer bei unseren familien treffen
sodass die omas immer gesagt haben wenn
man löcher in den hosen hatten haye ist
die aus dem altkleidercontainer muss das
so ich ziemlich kalt wir öffnen kasse
zweifelt sie einmal aber ich frage mich
an der stelle wirklich ist das nur in
deutschland so weil in anderen ländern
so gerade in amerika bin ich sagen hey
wie open bla bla bla bla bla us
amerikanischen late to für sprachen
lernen da gerade als ich in new york mit
jude war und wir beispielsweise bei
whole foods einkaufen waren und die dann
immer neue kasse gemacht haben die leute
sind krasser gesprintet als ahlmann wenn
es gerade sachen gibt im aldiana ahlmann
fünf minuten nachdem sie im urlaub
angekommen
[Musik]
es ist so die wahrheit vor wir sofort
weitermachen mit dem nächsten album
möchte ich allerdings wieder eine person
auf instagram pushen und zwar laser luca
fanpage 0 0
sie hat dieses bild hier hochgeladen
wenn ich versuche mein leben in den
griff zu bekommen und dann ja ich wie
ich den sonnenuntergang anfassen möchte
weil sie auch einen zerstörer im
nächsten video bekommen wollte er
markiert mich auf eure bilder net laser
luca einfach auf eurem bild markieren
und dann kommt ihr vielleicht mein
nächstes video passt ihre haben sie eine
palm an
nicht der einzige der keine payback
karte hat immer wenn ich mit julia
einkaufen wenn und die kassiererin
fragen haben sie eine payback karte
würde man ja klar hier bitte geben sie
wie die punkte wenn alba achim mallmann
annette auf großstadt besuch sind und
das erste mal über eine zeitlang wenn
ahlmann annette merkt dass die budgets
watson kettenbrief nicht innerhalb von
24 stunden an zehn freunde geschickt und
zwar meine mama hat derzeit die mal so
ein brief bekommen von wegen hey wenn
diese nach die weiterschicken bis morgen
ihr handy kaputt und den hat sie dann in
unsere familiengruppe geschickt dann mir
privat dann jule dann meine schwester
noch also das war auf jeden fall auch 11
wieder meine mom hier auf dem ihnen
gerade niemand wirklich einfach niemand
ahlmann moniz
ist halt auch immer diese sticker die
dann hinten drauf waren baby on board
ließ
genau genommen ahlmann annette um drei
uhr nachts die hat immer noch meine
tobago allgemeinen diese tupperdosen
sachen ich weiß nicht wie es bei euren
müttern ist aber bei mir als ich in der
schule war
und irgendwie brot mitgenommen oder so
ich habe einmal sonne so eine tupperware
box verloren und meine mom ist
ausgerastet
also wirklich kostet so eine box zehn
millionen euro da was ist da los als vor
dem schuhregal vans nein und ja das ist
ja da braucht man tatsächlich gar nicht
mehr viel zu sagen was allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten alba niemand
zwar ist das wirklich wieder zu 100%
true also es ist auch wirklich keine
übertreibung wie gerade bei den schulen
oder so sondern es ist wirklich 100%
ruhms was ist das hier ahlmann und er
hat etwas in der hand und auf dem
behälter steht herbst winter und das was
er auf der hand ist das hier
es gibt kein schlechtes wetter es gibt
nur falsche kleidung
das sind auch wieder zu 200.000 prozent
meiner eltern es wird herbst ahlmann
annette ja das ist auch wieder meine mum
niemand immer noch niemand als eine
sekunde nach der landung
und das ist ganz im ernst wieder 100
prozent und genauso wie wenn die leute
sagen hey check-in geht los die ränder
alle schon hin als als wenn die dann
sonst nicht mehr ins flugzeug rein
kommen würden alter schild doch mal am
flughafen wie ahlmann über geld sprechen
dafür haben wir kein geld wir können uns
das nicht leisten haben wir einen
goldesel
stehen das habe ich in meiner kindheit
hat sich etwas gekauft haben wollte für
meine eltern circa zehn mal täglich
gehört diesen satz kassiererin für das
schnellkochtopf set fehlen ihnen leider
noch zwei treuepunkte und die aktion
endet heute ahlmann
statt ist ja auch tatsächlich wieder
meine mom ahlmann
die leute sollen sich wirklich mal um
ihren eigenen kram kümmern auch ahlmann
der nachbar markt vom dritten mal
innerhalb eines jahres entgegen der
fahrtrichtung
er geht einfach nicht so keiner kann das
nicht gehen ich bin auch 100% ahlmann
ampel schaltet auf grün aymanns doppel
vom grüner wird's teams mit diesen
sprüchen die allmend sagen dass es das
stimmt zu zwei milliarden trillionen 400
mit der k 3 prozent
die ahlmann slogan gut gemacht prima
nicht schlecht herr und sandy war ein
echtes gold falsches gold und ahlmann
noch ein paar sekunden später ja ich bin
echt ein kranker ahlmann guten abend ja
ja ja das ist auch wieder war mallorca
alle mal los
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bergmann hat ahlmann muss man sein um
watson zu sagen serien zeit ist ahlmann
zeit ich bleibe dieses jahr zu hause ich
mache urlaub auf balkonien meine tante
so häufig gefahr ist da november alma
[Musik]
das kling ist hier in den rewe in köln
gibt es halt sogar schon oster sachen
und ich checks vorne hinten und im
quadrat milch nachbarn werfen nach 22
uhr einen müllsack in die tonne almanach
[Musik]
bevor das leute schreiben ich selbst
habe mir diese ein mann nicht ausgesucht
die wurden von einem kumpel rausgesucht
und er meinte ich habe eine krasse seite
gefunden youtube ein paar - raus packt
die die hier rein und du ri cha traurig
doppelpunkt existiere einmal nachbarn
muss die almanach teams zählen 22
es tut mir leid dass ich dir einfach nur
lachen
in diesem video aber ich finde die teile
so witzig wie bereits gesagt habe ich
euch dienstag an die seite von der diese
einmal - hier sind und in der video
beschreibung verlinkt also schaut auf
jeden fall gern mal vorbei dort werden
nahezu täglich neue gepostet allerdings
machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ihm und zwar ist es das hier
ich kann ich mal das salz haben einmal
nach ihm ob du das pan 20 nicht unter
krebs wieder voll ausrastet jugendlicher
art mit ahlmann oma früher war alles
besser
klar also nicht alle senioren sind so
also falls jemand hier über 60 70 sein
sollte meine videos schaut schaut an
dich ich hoffe dir geht's gut da im
rollator allerdings ist das hat auch
wieder die wahrheit gegen die finden
senioren immer gründe warum früher alles
besser war
oder auch dass hier t shirt im laden hat
kein preisschild ahlmann
dann gibt es das wohl umsonst es ist
auch wieder so ein typischer heim
anspruch allem an lehrer wenn auf der
klassen liste ein ausländischer name
erscheint es ist es soweit bei mir in
der grundschule es wurde jeder name von
türkischen freundin von mir wurde immer
falsch ausgesprochen oder ich weiß mich
eine lehrerin mal lutscher genannt hat
ja eine sternstunde ob wir nun
allerdings zum letzten mal für heute
meine damen und herren zwar ist das hier
ahlmann es auf partys normal tanzen nein
aber polonaise genau das ist unser ding
an der stelle ich das heute wieder ist
alles auch beenden meine lieben freunde
werden euch meine reaktion immer wieder
auf deutsche - beziehungsweise auf
einmal - gefallen hat dann dass ich mir
einen daumen unter dem video an schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare
ob ich noch mal auf deutsch - reagieren
soll zudem könnt ihr gerne die infobox
abchecken
da findet ihr meinen instagram verlinkt
und auch noch mal die seite wo mir diese
- heraus gesucht wurden und abonniert
auch gern meinen kanal jetzt noch kein
teil der lokalseite
[Musik]